you know it's been a little while since
since you've hung out with us have you
been I've been well uh well thank you
and good about things yeah I do feel
good where the 20s we made it to the 20s
sweaty sweaty yeah as I said when it
really starts to count do you think so
yeah because well in the last century
everybody started talking about the
decades from the 20s on right nobody was
like Oh 1909 that was really fun that's
true no one talked about that oh ten oh
give me some more 1913 yeah no one says
that no and I apologize to everyone that
your last 20 years meant nothing but now
that counted I'm okay with that
well this is we start from here and we
all made it so we're gonna do we're
gonna do great we're gonna do great
I like that optimistic man I am
optimistic I I definitely am an
optimistic person for sure and I really
feel like I feel like really good about
going forward now like I feel like I
feel like obnoxious a-holes have kind of
had a moment recently like they were
really very I mean they always existed
but they had like a coming-out party
over the last couple of years yeah you
know they're like you saw a lot more
testicles off the back of pickup trucks
yeah yeah yeah that was never before
right but now occasionally but now it
yeah you know it's like everybody's got
them yeah and I saw them on a Saab the
other day I saw him on a scooter but I
feel like now the pendulum will swing
and the good guys will come back and I
feel like yeah I feel like the good
people are going to have ammo
it's a nice thought yeah and III think
we have to we have to exact it's gonna
happen we have to participate you know
the good people have to side with all
the people that the a-holes are against
and we have to support them and then
we'll perform an army army of good
people Oh like like crying babies on
airplanes right I travel a lot and
there's always some obnoxious
businessman next to me
aggressively getting angry about a baby
because they're crying on an airplane
yeah well they should be crying they're
a baby on an airplane this is a horrible
situation it's horrible for everybody
this is this tube going 500 miles an
hour with gassy human beings we should
all be crying on the air the Green has
it right the baby is correct even
they're the only honest ones on the
plane yeah you know and we would all be
crying but we're too embarrassing just
mutter prayers into your Bloody Mary and
hopefully to the plane lands I don't
even I made a couple honey I don't like
them weird little haircuts I'm not a fan
but I'm supporting them and look if you
want to complain about toddlers flying
business class I'll listen to you I'll
listen yeah you have a problem with that
well yeah yeah I was first on the
upgrade list coming back here from New
York and I'm like oh I'm gonna fly like
a rich guy today I'm number one on the
list you always get it right not get it
everyone checked in full so I'm going
through business class looking who's in
my seat two toddlers had their own seats
in business class that's tough to take
that's tough to take
I'm trying to be optimistic about the
20s yes
and there's toddlers who are beating me
at life you had to pass them yeah and go
back and they were just sitting that was
crazy I know it's not their money but
they're working it I'm sitting in the
back eating pretzels like a praying
mantis
they both have emotions now is this the
kind of thing are you a guy that
complains in that situation or do you
ever do that are you one of those people
that ever it says I register a complaint
no no I slowly swallow the stress and
slowly lose my hair I don't I don't I
don't but you know look if it takes a
lot to get me aggravated like people
like that are playing their phones
without any kind of air pod or earbud
like you just think that facetiming next
to me out loud I want to kill you I
really want to go it's a huge violation
yeah but I hate conflict so I just kind
of swallow it yeah yeah and I really
think just like let's support the the
people that you know that you normally
would go against like customer service
people right anyone that works in
customer service I'm supporting them
anyone that has to work on a phone and
try and help people you know you don't
have to talk American to fix my laptop
you know what I mean right people like
screw you this is the young Indian kid
on the phone he's not gonna no no stop
it put yourself in his shoes do you
think he wants this job he doesn't want
this job can you imagine him telling his
friends that he got this job I got a job
today good for you what are you going to
do I'm gonna help Americans fix their
laptops over the phone
oh no you don't even have a laptop no
you don't even speak English I know I'd
start tomorrow and I had it I had yeah
it's a tough situation that we've both
been put in yeah I got a kid like that
on the phone when I was a troubled with
my laptop and I immediately he's like
hello I'm like oh no and I said no
that's what an obnoxious person would do
I said no I'm gonna be friends with him
I'm gonna let's get through this
together we've been put in this
situation neither of us wanna be in it
forces greater than us put us together
here let's get through it as friends yes
and I said what's your name they said my
name is Bob okay I'm trying to take us
further for all mankind and you start
off by lying to me okay
Big Bob you've got your reasons let's do
this let's fix this thing and he said
okay great and he started talking for
about five minutes and I didn't
understand a word he said and he put me
on hold for 20 times over the next hour
and a half and I just kept coming back I
just don't know and he left I was like
well you know what maybe I don't have a
laptop maybe anybody get a spiral
notebook exactly and he came back he was
so it was really like an hour and he
came back and he was so sad and as I'm
so sorry that this happened and I
apologize I said don't apologize we you
did okay Bob you did all right and he
said okay would you mind taking the
survey and telling him how I did I'm
like well you didn't do squat Bob you
didn't do a damn thing but I'll take
that survey because we did something
greater Bob we became friends over
continents and oceans to people from
very different backgrounds and we formed
a friendship or dare I say fell in love
and he said think and hung up on so that
was that you get never see Bob again
you'll never see him again you might you
never know